we are with Ray Robinson Ray first of
all how is how is this game because
Christopher was just like blitzing out
every single move giving you an exchange
for the attack how would you feel at
that point
yeah well it wasn't that pleasant but it
also wasn't that unpleasant it would
have been unpleasant if I didn't know
about this line at all but I I I did
fortunately so yeah Bishop D3 I knew I'm
supposed to take the exchange and it's
fine actually I thought maybe Black's
even supposed to be a little bit better
in this line but of course I didn't
remember everything so I knew take and
it feels like it's always about when you
started this line the last time when did
you study this line the last time oh
originally I yeah I probably studied a
while ago but fortunately sometime
during the tournament I like looked at
it for like you know two seconds so I
had a slightly better memory than I
would have but still I didn't actually
concretely remember anything except okay
new D6 G6 this position should
definitely be fine and I was almost
certain that Queen E7 should be the best
move but it's one of the moves Bishop to
E6 seems to be pretty decent as well
yeah that's the main other one I was
thinking about
um but then you guys to go into this
line
and now you have to go F5 and this type
of position
ah
yeah I I think I completely hallucinate
I thought like Queen D7 would I would
get mated somehow but like my night's
still covering and she said yeah so
maybe this one was also possible but I
think Queen E7 is probably what I
analyzed originally whenever I first
analyzed this so and if you do want to
equalize the position this seems to be a
very good uh path forward so I have to
take take the main I thought Knight D5
was the main thing I looked at and now I
think I should play Queen E5 the thing
is if I check on E1 Bishop F1 he always
has besides the mating thread says Queen
f8 check and Bishop H6 threats as well
so I thought for example if you let's
say you go something like this
page six and then that's a an extra
piece very nice so I thought Knight D5
Queen E5 and
um for some reason I thought C4 was what
I had analyzed and I was trying to
figure out why can't he take on C7
instead of C4
um and I figured probably it's Knight F5
uh he can't take his now back rank mate
so Queen F4
and now I can do check Bishop F1 and
something like Rook d8 so now he doesn't
have this moving his Bishop with Tempo
and now I counter attack him and
probably I win or something yeah I went
to C4 or something like Bishop D6 yeah I
assumed I was winning here yeah yeah
you're gonna get the Checkmate so yeah
Queen E5 C4 and I didn't remember you
know what's happening uh I mean what
exactly I should play but I knew I
should be okay instead he went Bishop G5
and he played it super fast yeah well he
knew both moves and I guess he just
decided to play this one I think he was
also trying to figure out if I still
knew this position or not
um and yeah I was thinking obviously
about Queen E5 as well and I think he
was gonna play Queen Bishop four yes
yeah he was saying it should be around
equal
um but I saw like F6 is very safe like
probably the line we go for is kind of
forced and I didn't think I would really
have any losing chances there so yeah in
the end I decided just to go for that
but obviously I didn't get many winning
chances I don't think either coming into
this uh game obviously have a point
behind Fabiano playing against Chris for
you who is struggling in the last few
rounds what are you trying to get
something out of the opening were you
trying to equalize what was your
strategy
yeah I was thinking at first I was like
oh yeah I should like really just go for
it I mean I would really be great to at
least be tied going to the last round
but uh that's not really the way I
usually play with black these days and
then in the end I decide okay I'm just
gonna play normally just play my normal
openings and he usually goes for a fight
so even against you know stronger high
rated players so I was hoping yeah we
might get a game and then we just see
what would happen but
um
yeah obviously I I never expected this
line I mean he doesn't usually go for
the Berlin and then
I was thinking okay maybe just gotta
like make a quiet draw and then of
course he went for the bishop D3 so it
was kind he kind of reverted back to his
usual style anyway but yeah it seemed
like he was just well prepared Jeffrey
tomorrow with the white pieces in the
final round is the must win for you
I assume I don't know how fabi's doing
is he like uh winning or something no
probably no okay probably more like a
draw yeah because I was trying to figure
out when this bishop before move
yeah move 22 that was I left what so ah
I saw an A5 is Bishop A5 I guess right
yes because I was thinking what if he
tries A5 A4 and then the idea that
Bishop C5 yeah but I guess you could
just take an A5 yes you can take on A5
they seems to be pretty decent well yeah
so if I'm half Point behind Fabiano I
mean I think he's white against LeBron
yeah
um so it is a must win I would say if I
want to have a chance to tie
um
yeah that's always difficult situation I
think I was in the same situation once
in U.S championship
um and going to the last round I was
halfway behind it Carl he was gonna yeah
he's gonna be white against onishek I
was going to be black against Korea and
I managed to win that game but
unfortunately he also managed to win
um so at least I did I did the best I
could I could in that game I'll try to
do that again tomorrow
um I think I've had five draws and three
wins and then a bunch more draws so
hopefully I can get squeeze one more win
in um for the end of the tournament but
uh yeah it's been been a really tough
tournament guys yeah congratulations Ray
all as success for you tomorrow in the
final round and uh well keep up the good
work yeah looking forward because it's I
hope we will still have this motivation
you spoke that you really want to win
one day the US Championship so it's
gonna be really interesting fight
tomorrow looking forward thank you
absolutely uh